Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number which is
2192. David, you can call any time. Here's a
caller who has a very specific question for me.
Speaker 2: David Mattingly, what would
it take you to go to a NASCAR race?
Speaker 1: Okay. I have never been to
a NASCAR race. I don't really care about NASCAR.
I don't find it interesting. But I don't have any
real opposition to going. I don't know if there
are NASCAR races in like the Northeast. I'm just
not sure. Maybe up north, like in upstate New
York, it's the type of I know upstate New York is
is pretty conservative and rural. Maybe maybe up
there are not even upstate like western New York,
northwestern New York, maybe there. I would go
to a NASCAR race. It wouldn't really be for the
racing. The racing seems quite boring, but it
would be more as a socio cultural I would go
as an anthropologist, I think is what I'm saying.
All right. So if someone wants to take me, baby,
well documented, we've got a great bonus show
for you today. We're going to talk about the
rules package passed by Republicans. We're going
to talk about what's going on with IRS funding and
Republicans. And we will talk about how Cunanan
is responding to the Brazil riots and more when
producer Pat joins me. Sign up at join Pacman
dot com get instant access. It's a great thing.